Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Sì, sono un giornalista.
E mi dichiaro "non colpevole", anche se sono tra gli indiziati.
Sono anche un cittadino italiano, e vorrei sapere come stanno le cose, davvero.
E poi sono un amante, come è stato detto, di TED.
Di TED, di Media Lab, di tanti (o troppo pochi) luoghi
nei quali c'è insieme informazione, ispirazione, esempi di persone straordinarie.
E ci sono curatori, come quelli che hanno organizzato TEDxLakeComo,
che hanno gusto per cercare queste cose.
E poi c'è la cosa fondamentale: un pubblico che ti fa sentire a casa,
che la pensa in modo tale che ti sembra di averli già conosciuti da sempre.
Come cittadino italiano, certamente questa non è la mia esperienza normale.
Anzi, devo dire che vorrei sapere come stanno le cose,
ma non so in nessun modo come gli altri pensano di scoprire come stanno le cose.
Come giornalista, vi racconto quello che sta succedendo:
il fango di Genova, e il fango dei mercati finanziari, il fango di tutte quelle storie
che ci siamo raccontati per anni, e che sono collegate con i fatti che succedono,
ma molto di più con il modo in cui li pensiamo e li vediamo.
Per mettere insieme queste tre identità, che sono poi quello che ciascuno di noi vive,
ho tre domande, che vi porto, e una proposta.
Le tre domande vengono da fatti che mi sono successi:
un momento straordinario della mia vita recentemente è stato andare,
essere invitato a parlare al Media Lab, la grande scuola e centro di studi
di Cambridge al MIT. Mi hanno chiesto di parlare dell'esperienza che stavo vivendo
nella ricerca sui nuovi media: l'ho fatto, e sono stati tutti contenti,
studenti, professori, PhD hanno ascoltato, fatto domande. Finito tutto questo,
a uno a uno sono venuti da me e mi hanno più o meno tutti fatto la stessa domanda:
ma perché gli italiani non si ribellano?
(lungo applauso)
Per ribellarsi, ci sono tante condizioni:
una di queste è sapere insieme a chi ti ribellerai, per ottenere che cosa,
sulla base di quale diagnosi e di quali fatti che conosciamo insieme
possiamo farlo: quelli del Media Lab mi hanno chiesto così, più o meno, pensando che noi, essendo vicini alla Tunisia,
potevamo fare come loro.
Non sono comunisti: sono americani!
Ma la loro idea è che, di fronte ad una situazione che va cambiata, si deve fare qualcosa.
Per farlo, la nostra idea, la nostra esperienza è che bisogna sentirsi insieme,
per fare questa cosa. C'è un'analisi che ho imparato negli ultimi dieci giorni,
vista e raccontata da un professore che si chiama Dan Kahan, a Yale,
che definisce una condizione sociale particolarmente grave
e simile a quella che noi conosciamo.
Lui lo chiama "cognitively illiberal state",
uno stato (di cose) che è illiberale dal punto di vista cognitivo.
Qual è questo stato di cose? È uno stato di cose nel quale la differenza di valori,
di ideologie, di modi di vedere le cose e di giudicarle è talmente grande
che in una società non c'è nessun modo per sapere come stanno i fatti, come stanno le cose,
senza che questo venga interpretato come una opinione,
come una presa di posizione: non si può parlare di un fatto senza far credere
o sembrare sostenitori di una posizione ideologica o di un'altra.
Cognitively illiberal state.
Se noi ci pensiamo come democrazia tranquilla e felice non faremo ribellione, ma
se ci pensiamo come uno stato illiberale, uno stato autoritario dal punto di vista cognitivo,
allora una forma di ribellione la possiamo creare,
mettendoci insieme. Mettersi insieme è la terza questione:
ho l'impressione che quello che abbiamo fatto con i social network e Internet,
i blog, facebook sia stato grandioso: ha rimesso in discussione tutto il sistema dei media!
Il giornalista che è in me ha vissuto questi ultimi dieci anni
dovendo confrontarmi con un soggetto straordinario, nuovo, ricchissimo di capacità,
di creatività che è stato questo pubblico attivo, che ha contribuito all'informazione,
l'ha criticata, l'ha fatta girare, l'ha fatta diventare più importante
ed è diventato un soggetto con il quale ci si confronta estremamente importante.
Ma non è chiaro come, sui social network, si mettano insieme gruppi di società diversi.
In realtà, così come stanno le cose - le piattaforme, in questo momento,
stanno valorizzando i modi veloci con i quali ci si connette, ci si riconosce,
ci si gratifica. È questa velocità è legata al fatto che si va d'accordo facilmente.
Questa è una dinamica che si sta osservando un po' dappertutto
e fa in modo che ci si trovi fondamentalmente con altre persone simili.
Si creano dei gruppi, delle isole culturali, ancora una volta separate
(come nel cognitively illiberal state) nel quale contano gli atteggiamenti culturali,
le posizioni ideologiche, quello che si vuole ottenere, l'attivismo e quant'altro.
Non è tutto così, non è Internet che crea questo:
sono alcune pratiche che in questa fase dello sviluppo di Internet stanno, in questo momento, prevalendo.
È chiaro che non è tutto così perché,
come ci ha dimostrato Frieda Brioschi, il progetto Wikipedia è un progetto
nel quale tutti conducono e producono qualche cosa insieme.
Sto parlando di altre piattaforme come, per l'appunto, Facebook, o Twitter,
dove ci si trova facilmente e velocemente con persone simili.
Siamo talmente abituati a persone simili, che non ci rendiamo conto
di alcune differenze, nella nostra società, che sono fulminanti.
Per me, la più fulminante delle scoperte è quella che, per l'appunto,
c'è anche su Wikipedia Italia [e] riporta i dati sull'analfabetismo in Italia,
l'analfabetismo funzionale: le persone che, leggendo il giornale,
non capiscono cosa leggono.
Persone testate per quello che riescono a leggere e a capire di quello che leggono.
Persone che, forse, decifrano quello che significano i segni scritti,
ma che non capiscano che cosa vogliano dire.
E il numero, in Italia, di persone che sono funzionalmente analfabete,
secondo una ricerca dell'OCSE e dell'ONU, è il 47%.
Non c'è paese occidentale che abbia questa cifra.
Io non ne conosco neanche uno, non so voi.
Il mio mondo è chiuso intorno a quelli che leggono, e leggono tanto.
Che adottano una dieta mediatica molto ampia, molto ricca, con un sacco di cose:
Internet, giornali, libri, persino un po' di televisione! (Risate)
Eppure, quasi la metà di noi non capisce quello che c'è scritto.
E... scusate, i test sono stati fatti, in Italia, sulla Gazzetta Dello Sport! (Risate).
Quarantasette per cento. Secondo Tullio De Mauro, la percentuale è anche superiore,
ma lui è un professore molto severo: lui è andato a guardare il manuale che l'ISTAT fornisce
a quelli che fanno le interviste su quanti leggono libri, in Italia.
E ha scoperto che quando una persona risponde: “No, non leggo libri”,
il manuale prevede che l'intervistatore debba andare a chiedere un'altra domanda del tipo:
"Ma non ha mai letto nemmeno un libro di cucina?"
E questo porta qualcuno di quelli che hanno detto "non leggo libri" a dire:
"si, beh, un libro di cucina, in effetti [sì.]"
Tullio De Mauro dice che siamo a livelli peggiori, ma a me basta il 47%.
Che cosa ci portano a dire queste osservazioni e queste condizioni nelle quali siamo?
C'è una grande opportunità che è Internet - grande apertura, grande partecipazione,
grande energia innovativa. C'è una situazione di frammentazione, nella società,
tale per cui io non conosco nessuno di questa metà della popolazione italiana
che non sa capire quello che legge, se legge.
E c'è una condizione nella quale l'ideologia, la differenza valoriale,
separa così tanto che io non posso sapere quali sono i fatti
perché i fatti vengono sempre presentati come come se fossero
a sostegno di alcune posizioni rispetto ad altre.
Ultimo esempio (ma vi prego, scandalizzatevene con me): c'è stato un dibattito,
sia in Toscana che in Veneto, relativamente al fatto che è ora di finirla,
con queste previsioni del tempo, perché quando le previsioni del tempo
dicono che piove si diminuisce il turismo nelle città d'arte,
dove questo - e questo significa avere reso opinione
anche le previsioni del tempo. Noi siamo in questa condizione! (Risate e applausi)
Ma Internet è una grande opportunità.
Non tanto perché, così com'è, funziona e fa tutto, mette tutto a posto.
Internet è una grande opportunità perché non cessa di alimentare
la possibilità di innovare ancora un po', di aggiungere un altro tassello
al percorso che stiamo facendo e che, vi ricordo, è molto breve:
non abbiamo conosciuto Internet da tanto tempo.
In Italia, nel 1995, erano 100.000 persone connesse, e adesso siamo arrivati, nel 2011,
a superare la metà, dice il Censis, dei connessi.
Tra l'altro, quest'anno è l'anno in cui, per la prima volta,
quattro referendum sono stati vinti da quelli che sostenevano il Sì
nonostante la bassa, bassissima informazione che è stata data in televisione,
e nonostante che i giornali stiano vendendo sempre di meno
e non raggiungano la maggioranza della popolazione.
E tutti gli osservatori hanno detto che il 55% degli italiani che è andato a votare
lo ha fatto informandosi con Internet.
Internet è importante, e si può migliorare.
La proposta che vi lascio, negli ultimi 3 minuti e 44 secondi
è relativa a una fondazione che è nata a Trento,
sulla base del grande distretto della ricerca che c'è là,
che si propone di aggiungere pezzettini di innovazione a Internet
che vadano nella direzione di incentivare un comportamento
di chi fa informazione in rete orientato a condividere un metodo simile,
comune, con il quale si definisce quello che è informazione
e quello che non lo è. La fondazione si chiama ahref,
perché è parte del codice html con il quale si scrivono le pagine Internet,
ed è quella parte che fa cominciare i link.
Quindi ogni link comincia sempre con un ahref, anche se il browser non ce lo mostra.
La fondazione dei link.
Una delle cose che ha fatto è stata lanciare questa piattaforma,
che si chiama Timu, che in swahili vuol dire "facciamo squadra, squadra",
e lì vengono chiamati a partecipare cittadini che vogliono fare informazione,
segnalare l'informazione che già fanno su tutti i media che adesso possono utilizzare.
Vengono proposte - è aperta a organizzazioni, fondazioni, aziende
che vogliano lanciare delle inchieste, ad autorità locali che vogliano sostenere,
supportare i cittadini che vogliono fare queste inchieste:
tutti, insieme, accettano però che su Timu si faccia informazione
sulla base di un metodo condiviso, molto semplice, del tipo:
farò informazione in modo accurato, dichiarando in modo trasparente
i miei eventuali conflitti di interesse, e perché faccio certe cose.
Dicendo che seguirò la legge, e verificherò le fonti.
Un metodo che favorisce, e rende possibile, fare in modo che i cittadini
dichiarino in modo aperto, un modo per fare l'informazione,
e che quelli che incontrano quello che i cittadini, in questo modo,
producono informazione, leggono e si informano
con quello che viene prodotto da lì,
sappiano qual è perlomeno l'intento che quei cittadini hanno seguito.
Non c'è nessun altro modo per far funzionare questo sistema
che non sia semplicemente la dichiarazione spontanea di una responsabilità
che i cittadini possano prendersi, per fare informazione.
Un'informazione accurata, trasparente, che verifica le fonti
e che si dichiara orientata a seguire la legge.
Ma se lo si dichiara esplicitamente, ci si prende una responsabilità nei confronti degli altri,
ci si fa conoscere in quanto vogliosi di prendersi questa responsabilità
e si incontrano gli altri cittadini su un altro piano:
un piano nel quale, prima di discutere delle opinioni,
ci si mette d'accordo su come si può sapere come stanno le cose.
Io credo che questo potrebbe aiutarci.
(Applausi)